I love Rihanna down to like that's my
girl but like I think they squashed it
so why should I beef him why do you
think there is a public outcry for the
Chris Brown and Rihanna situation
however there was not the same outcry
when cardi B publicly admitted to
drinking and robbing men a lot of things
that happen to women are predominantly
done by men so obviously like we're all
target men for things that they do
obviously us we're very scared like we
go outside we see a man we want to run
but obviously with cardi B in that like
we are like kind of we're kind of like
saying oh that's girl power yeah do that
to that man but honestly I don't agree
though